c'est un haut lieu des nuits parisiennes
qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous le
lido quelque chose de féerique les
paillettes qui brillait
voilà des joli joli ce parent voilà il
fait chaud lido et ce depuis 1946 dans
les années 50 charlie chaplin brigitte
bardot et le tout-paris s'y pressent
pour admirer les fameuses revue du
cabaret à paris enfin le lido a inauguré
avec la fin de l'année un nouveau
programme étincelant du à pierre louis
guérin et rené fradet et dont la
réalisation ne fait pas mentir le titre
c'est magnifique
à l'origine de ces revues un homme
notamment il s'appelle pierre louis
guérin c'est le directeur emblématique
du lido pendant près de 40 ans je vais
vous dire une chose c'est peut-être
beaucoup de peine mais les étrangers
viennent à paris eh bien ils viennent
d'abord voir la vidéo qui pour voir le
louvre
et que serait le lido sans ses danseuses
les bluebell girls
margaret kelly surnommée miss bluebell
les dirige depuis 1948 et gare à celles
qui seraient en retard pour les
répétitions
tout le monde est là disait quelqu'un
est en retard vous surveiller
oui à
la
taille minimum pour devenir une bluebell
girls 1 m 75 les voici en 1967 avec leur
plus beau costume pour une nouvelle
revue mesdames et messieurs rideau
ok
[Musique]
et c'est vers toi que je re
dix ans plus tard en 1977 le lido
s'agrandit 6000 m² de surfaces
supplémentaires
regardez ces images c'est complètement
fou sous la scène un système de tiroir
est installé pour sortir des décors et
les rangées comme sur un porte-avions ça
représente un effort nda oui pourquoi la
salle parce que d'abord à l'emplacement
au sens elysées était pas de plain pied
il a fallu creuser il a fallu organiser
d'une machinerie c'est énorme ce
considérable comme cela est bien entendu
ça a mis en cause d'une vingtaine
d'entreprises différentes le lido rénové
de nouveau spectacle voit le jour
toujours plus spectaculaire comme en
2006 année des 60 ans de la célèbre
salle de spectacle pour cette 28ème
revue on est repris en plus fastueux les
bonnes vieilles recettes longues jambes
gainées de soins
plus les strass à foison
23 des corps différents pour un tour du
monde en une heure 40 15 ans plus tard
en décembre 2021 le lido est racheté par
accor le géant de l'hôtellerie veut
transformer le cabaret pour en faire une
salle de spectacles musicaux terminé lé
célèbre revue des 184 postes actuels 157
seront supprimés a annoncé le groupe
accor
[Musique]